And this brings me to my final point of today's
show.
These abortion bans also highlight something
else, not just the Republican Party's war
on women or their disdain for science, but
it's the fact that this Republican Party,
as we know it today, has not had a new idea
in 40 years.
Not One, three things.
This Republican Party has been pushing for
the last 40 years.
One, cut taxes for the wealthy and let it
trickle down to the workers to cut all regulations
so businesses can do whatever the hell they
want.
And three, don't let women have abortions.
Yeah,
40 years longer than I've been on this planet
by the way.
They have been pushing those same three tired
and worn out ideas that do not work.
I honestly want people to think about that
fact for a moment.
This is a party that hasn't had a new idea
for the entire time that the millennial generation
has been alive ever since Reagan first came
into office and started pushing this a failed
theory of trickle down economics.
That was it.
Reagan also ushered in the era of deregulation
that also tanked the economy, by the way,
and of course the religious right who latched
onto Reagan with the antiabortion movement,
but ever since then, Republicans have done
nothing to actually benefit the American public,
the working class, the average people out
here in this country, they've done plenty
to benefit the wealthy elite plenty.
The tax cuts, the deregulation, all of that
benefits them.
The abortion thing is just to keep their a
bass a little drummed up while they rob them
because that's what's happened.
You know, we're making up for the fact that
wealthy people don't have to pay as much in
taxes.
You know, we're getting hosed on that.
We may not be paying more because of that.
Some of us are actually under the current
tax plan.
Some of us are, but what I mean is our schools
properly funded.
Our kids are using textbooks that are 15 to
20 years old.
We're paying higher prices for medications.
We're paying for the trade wars.
We're seeing college prices skyrocket.
We're getting screwed over by the big banks.
They robbed our pension funds in 2007 and
2008 and got bailed out instead of thrown
in prison.
Yeah,
we've been paying the price this whole time
for the Republicans policies and the Democrats
went along with some of these too, by the
way, but the only reason these people keep
voting Republican, knowing that this party
hasn't had a new idea since Reagan is because
of the abortion thing.
That's what keeps them coming back.
You have the culture war issues.
That's it.
When you go to the polls in 2020 I want you
to ask yourself this.
I hope you ask yourself this prior to going
to the polls because you probably need to
think about it.
When was the last time the Republicans had
an idea that benefited the middle class, the
working class, the underclass.
When, I mean, we were told earlier this year
multiple different times that their healthcare
plan was right around the corner.
We're going to get it next week.
They went to Camp David a couple of weekends
ago to work this out and they came up with
nothing.
Trump told us on Twitter, Hey, get ready.
It's coming in April.
Oops.
It didn't come in April.
Now he says that it's going to come after
2020 listen to me, you're a party that's been
running on repealing Obamacare for nearly
10 years.
You've had time to come up with a health care
policy.
You failed to do it because you don't know
what you're doing.
If it's not a tax cutter, deregulation or
an abortion, you're clueless and you're lost,
and that is exactly what the Republican Party
is today.
They're clueless.
They're lost and they haven't had a single
good idea since long before I was born and
the only ideas they've had in the last 40
years.
There was three that I've talked about have
been absolute train wrecks for the United
States.
Look, I am Farron cousins.
Thank you very much for tuning in today.
Thank you to David for letting me sit in today.
I will be back tomorrow to fill in once again.
In the meantime, follow me on Twitter at fair
and balanced also on Instagram and on Facebook
at fair and balanced and stay tuned for the
bonus show.
Got a great new report from media matters,
showing that Fox News, even on their newsy
programs is still lying to the public every
day.
And also the,
Oh says that Ben Carson, definitely both the
law.
I'm very cousins.
Thank you for watching the David Pakman show.